حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط
هجوم اوكراني استخدمت فيه مسيرات ضد اهداف
في العاصمه موسكو واضافت الوزاره ان احدى
المسيرات التي تم اعتراضها تحطمت في منطقه
موسكو سيتي بعد فقدان سيطره عليها وكان
رئيس بلديه العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
صبيانين قد قال ان دفاعات الجويه اسقطت
عددا من الطائره المسيره في سبع المدينه
المسؤول الروسي اشار الى ان احدى المسيرات
ضربت برجا كان قد استهدف الاسبوع الماضي
وكتب سبيان على تطبيق تيليجرام ان طائره
مسيره وصلت الى نفس البرج في مجمع
موسكفاسيتي الذي اصيب في السابق في
الاثناء افادت مراسله الجزيره في موسكو
انه تم فتح مطار فنكوغو الدولي في موسكو
بعد اغلاقه مؤقتا غضون ذلك اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدمير ثلاث زوارقه مسيره
اوكرانيه اثناء صد هجوم على اسطول البحر
الاسود الوزاره وصفت الهجوم بالمحاوله
الفاشله لمهاجمه سفن اصول البحر الاسود
جنوب غرب
بثلاثه قوارب مسيره المقابل قالت قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان الاسطول
الروسي اعزز من وجود سفنه الجاهزه للمهام
القتاليه في البحر الاسود كما اضافت في
بيان ان هناك سفينتين وغواصه عسكريه روسيه
لاداء هذه المهمه
قياده العمليه الاوكرانيه الى ان 16
صاروخا من نوع كاليبر اصبحت جاهزه للاطلاق